[Music]
hey there guardian looking pretty buff
hit level 20 I see grats grats so now
what expiain going to level you up like
it used to and there's this weird light
situation going on and all these weapons
are way too expensive and what even is a
mode of light well just take a deep
breath remember that you're still
humanity's only hope in this crazy world
and your only hope for leveling up
taking on high-level raids and getting
legendary gear is to pick up all the
knowledge I'm about to drop first things
first let's get to level it you want to
push north of 20 you're gonna need gear
with light on it equip light gear and
gain light gain enough light and level
up so one of the ways you can get light
gear number one the same way you got
gear before dummy any story missions you
replay can still drop gear and because
your level 20 that gear stands a chance
of carrying light number two Vanguard
missions hit up the strike playlist and
you're guaranteed to walk away with a
piece of light gear well almost
guaranteed there's still a bit of
randomness in play here or as I like to
call it bungees insidious plot to
demoralize and defraud me by not
dropping what I need and/or want number
three crucible missions same deal as
Vanguard missions same degree of
randomness slash evil plot at least a
variety of battling other Guardians
beats the repetition of running the
exact same Vanguard missions over and
over again unless you're into that sort
of thing I guess I'm not gonna judge you
but the final and most reliable way to
acquire light gear is number four buying
gear from one of the many vendors in the
tower and this is where things get
tricky see because you can't just roll
up to a quartermaster with a fistful of
glimmer and a twinkle in your eye you
need the right reputation and you need
the right currency let's start with rep
there are three kinds of reputation
Vanguard crucible and faction specific
you earn Vanguard rep from strike
missions and patrol missions you're in
crucible rep from fighting in the
crucible you earn faction specific rep
from doing any of these activities
anything that gets you any kind of rep
at all while wearing a faction specific
fashion statement aka class armor so by
a beach towel from the future war cult a
hip
sash from dead orbit or a bedazzled
bangle from new monarchy and all the rep
you earn while wearing it will go to
that specific faction reputation which
raises the question which faction should
you choose near mocking do bit of a
future war cult you can check their
stocks to get an idea for the aesthetic
style and practical stats of the stuff
each faction has to offer and each one
favors two of the three armor attributes
discipline intellect and strength but
the bigger question is is it worth
pouring all your rep into a specific
faction or sticking with a straight-up
Vanguard and crucible reputation pools
there are a few things to consider when
making this decision but basically it
boils down to this if you don't mind or
even enjoy playing competitive
multiplayer choose a faction if you only
ever want to shoot aliens stick with the
normal Vanguard then pick up all the
daily bounties complete all the daily
bounties and boost that rep until it
hits level 2 once you hit that threshold
go ahead and buy yourself a legendary
piece of light armor you've determined
hey way to go champ
looking sharp so now that light gear is
the only thing that boosts your level
what is XP good for you're knocking out
these bounties and just gobbling down XP
but for what
well XP still levels up your gear it
still unlocks skills for your subclass
and now it also goes towards the
generation of motes of light this is a
kind of rare currency so there's got to
be someone around here who's selling
something good right oh hey speaker what
do you got there buddy
oh cool just like a bunch of class armor
and emblems I see one of the rarest
currencies and then came for some
cosmetic doodads okay cool but I'll
check you later bye
come on there's gotta be someone around
here who's got the goods I got all these
motes of light burning a hole in my
pocket
oh hey who's that guy he wasn't here
during the weekdays let's go and ask him
excuse me sir what are you boy in holy
space tentacles Batman I mean um I mean
uh what what are you selling an exotic
Engram for motes of light hmm did
a gamble there but so shiny oh and a few
gear bits for the brilliantly named
strange coins now that's the kind of
tangibility I like his stock changes
every weekend but it seems that if you
want a sure thing from this Zorro fella
you'll need strange coins best place to
grab those is the weekly strike
providing you've got the light gear to
take it on the higher level you are the
more difficulty tiers you can run it on
and the more coins you can reap but the
weekly strike is more of a mid twenties
kind of thing so once you hit that level
20 threshold make your reputation
decision about a faction versus Vanguard
and crucible then rock those bounties
boost that rep and buy your way to
higher and higher levels if you find
that you're easily fulfilling bounties
and want a way to really go after better
gear then you my friend are entering the
grind zone welcome to the grind so do
not attempt to play levels normally do
not go to a random place start killing
do we have certain methods and locations
for maximum fine rewards please consult
the GameSpot video titled destiny
legendary and glimmer farming spots and
tips for more information and enjoy your
stay in the grinds oh and there you have
it guardian your guide to pushing past
level 20 and into the glorious realms of
legendary loot and hard as balls strike
missions if you have any tips of your
own or want to find some skilled players
to party up with sound off in the
comments below
in the coming months we'll be grinding
our way ever onwards and upwards to
bring you high level tips and strategies
so be sure to make gamespot your destiny
destination your destination um sorry
I'll just show myself
you